-I am hanging out with
Julianne Moore, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Her new series "Lisey's Story"
premieres on Apple TV+ June 4th.
Now Julianne, I wanted to tr
something fun with you.
I thought we could act out a
dramatic scene together.
-Oh. I love acting.
-Yeah.
But first, we have to
fill in the blanks.
It is time for
"Mad Lib Theater." Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪♪ Mad Lib Theater, yeah
-Here's how this works.
I'm going to ask you for som
silly words nouns, verbs,
adjectives, etc.
and as we do that they'll be
written on the cue cards.
And then we're going to act ou
a dramatic "Mad Libs" scene.
You ready for this?
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
Male first and last name.
-Barack Obama.
-Three first names.
-Charlie, Pinkie, Beyoncé.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
An adjective.
-Oh, smashingly.
-Oh, smashing.
-Or smashing.
-Smashing.
Three words that rhyme.
-Knicks, kicks, licks.
-Knicks, kicks, and licks.
Okay. Another adjective.
-Fluffy.
-Yeah.
A number.
-3,928.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
A price.
-$999.99.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Something gray, something blue
and something green.
Gray?
-A dolphin.
-Dolphin.
What's blue?
-Gatorade.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And something green?
-Mint chip ice cream.
-[ Gasps ] That's my jam.
-Yeah, right?
-That's my jam.
A plural noun.
-Couches.
[ Laughter ]
-A verb ending in -ing.
-Shaving.
-Plural body part.
-Ass cheeks.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Alright.
This is the speed round.
-Animal.
-Aardvarks.
-The sound a horse would make.
-Whinny.
-Favorite dinner food.
-Salmon.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Cartoon character or mascot
-Lightning McQueen.
-Adjective.
-Um, dumb.
-Yeah.
Plural type of animal.
-Poodles.
-Celebrity.
-Brad Pitt.
-Year and model
of your first car.
-Volvo, 1995.
-Yeah!
-Alright. Perfect.
We have filled out the words
Are you ready to perform our
scene?
-Yeah.
-Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome back to QVC.
I'm your host, Barack Obama.
And with me today is glamour
guru Charlie Pinkie Beyoncé.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Charlie.
-I'm glad to be here,
Barack Obama.
Today we're going to talk abou
some of the most smashing
trends for this summer.
-Knicks, kicks, licks.
I'm so excited.
[ Laughter ]
-I am too. Now, first up we have
these fluffy sunglasses.
-They really are.
They really are.
-Yeah.
Oh, they're brand new
this season and available in
3,928 easy payments
of $999.99.
-Wow, interesting.
That's very easy payments.
They come in many differen
colors, including dolphin gray
Gatorade blue, and of course
the most popular,
mint chip ice cream green.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They may look like your typical
sunglasses, but no, they're not.
-No way.
-These sunglasses are made
from 100% recycled couches
-Interesting.
They're the perfect thing to
wear while shaving on the beach.
I will say that. Okay, let's see
what we have next here.
Oh, look at this right here.
-Whoo!
Feast your ass cheeks on thi
Vitamix margarita blender here
-It is our newest model that
uses aardvark-powered motor.
[ Applause ]
-That goes from the speed of
zero to whinny!
[ Laughter ]
-I just want everyone to kno
the reason your margaritas are
so exceptional
is because your secret
ingredient is salmon.
[ Laughter ]
-That's true, Barack Obama
-Let's give it a whirl here.
Come on.
[ Blender grinding ]
Do you have any vacation plans
this summer?
-Oh, yes.
I'm going to visit my colleg
friend, lightning McQueen.
-Okay. Let's pour it into thes
glasses right here.
-Oh here, I have one.
-Oh, perfect. Unbelievable
Look, as always, we will do ou
cheersing like we always do --
we've still got time?
-Yeah.
-We still have time.
Okay, cheers.
-Cheers --
cheers to dumb poodles.
-Cheers to Brad Pitt
and cheers to Volvo '95.
[ Cheers and applause ]
End scene.
We'll be right back.
Thank you Charlie.
I'm Barack Obama.
We'll be right back with
Dave Bautista, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪